hi
everyone i'm ying product manager
working on
ai and industry solutions at google
cloud
in this session i will be sharing with
you how our visual inspection
ai products support manufacturing
customers to transform their business
sudhi from accenture will also be
joining me in this session
would you want to introduce yourself
sudhi thank you
for your partnership support and for
giving us an opportunity to present at
google next
hello everyone i'm sudhindra from
accenture responsible for building
industry solutions on google cloud
and part of accenture google business
group
cool so besides the two of us tigran and
alex as siemens also created a video
to share their adoption story for our
visual inspection product
in the end of this session we will get a
chance to take a look at the video
so let's get started
in the current market demand volatility
puts lots of
pressure on manufacturers the decreased
demand
for the new product the disruption of
the retail channels
and the interruption of the supply train
operation
make it really challenging for the
manufacturers to maintain business
continuity the manufacturers are
motivated
to decrease cost and improve work
efficiency
by automating many of their work
processes
visual inspection technologies are there
to help
but the adoption of these new
technologies can be difficult and costly
the traditional inspection devices cost
millions of dollars per device the
deployment
and the adoption of these new
technologies require the support
of the i.t infrastructures and the
domain experts
the limited amount of sample data make
it really challenging to
analyze the product quality and to train
machine learning models
for automating the visual quality
control process
to solve all these challenges google has
partnered
with several of the industry leaders
to build a best-in-class vision
inspection technology
to help the manufacturing customers
really transform
their business we have a rich
computer vision product offering
it includes the preaching the apis the
automl product
and several of the new products that we
are building to support the industry
specific use cases
all of this product will be available on
gcp very soon end of last year
forrester has ranked google cloud as a
leader for the computer vision product
both because its current product
offering
and its future product strategy our
visual inspection product
could be used to support a variety of
the use cases
for example cosmetic inspection for the
electronic
product and assembly inspection
to look for missing or damaged component
on the assembled product
weld inspection for the automotive
manufacturing
with earlier inspection for
semiconductors
and the packaging material inspection
for consumer packaged goods
one of our lighthouse customers fosscon
fh they built a visual inspection
solution
using our visual inspection product
for the six components they want to
inspect
on the assembled pcb assembly board
we have them achieved lower than one
percent
of the defect escape rate and false
alarm rate
by deploying this solution they achieved
significantly cost saving on their
production lines
another of our lighthouse customer is
global foundries
they use our product for inspecting the
wafer layers
this helped them improve the inspection
rate
to over 95 percent within few months
of starting to implement this solution
they successfully migrated over 40
percent of the
manual workload to this automated
solution
this helped them scale the automatic
solution much
faster than they expect
in the next session i will hand it over
to sudhi
for him to share about how accenture
has been partnering with google for
building visual inspection solutions
thank you i would like to start giving
an overview of our partnership with
google
the accenture google business group has
formed about five years ago
and it is designed to bring the best of
google human centric design technology
and innovation with accenture's
capability industry experience and
intelligence
accenture's ai visual inspection
offering enables multiple industry use
cases
for an enterprise through a platform
based approach
what this means for our client is an
ai-based visual inspection platform
running on google cloud offering
automated and improved inspection
solutions
in the area of quality control safety
surveillance
asset tracking and diagnosis covering
both
in production and non-production
environments
for multiple industries our key business
value focuses on reducing inspection
time
the inspection cost and
defaults positive cases and false
negative cases
our platform is architectured to offer
flexibility
to run ai services both on the cloud and
edge
addressing practical requirements in the
client environment
as part of our hardware solution
offering accenture can help with
advanced imagery solutions recommending
the best camera and installation for the
solution required
we provide automation services for
inspection use cases
supporting with the integration
such as with the robotics and drone
based solutions
in addition to cloud our ai services run
on the edge
channels such as mobile devices and iot
gateways
for edge scenarios iot gateways equipped
with google tpus and google
corel are our primary recommendation to
run visual inspection
the key consideration to include edge ai
is to support use cases that require
almost zero latency
for example running visual inspection
and capturing
objects on a video with 3200 frames per
second
providing data privacy and supporting
low bandwidth scenarios
we provide energy enabled android and
ios mobile app services
and for the iot gateways we offer an
enterprise grade
edge stack that consists of cloud
connectivity
security cloud-based orchestration and
software updates through google cloud
our edge application run layer running
visual inspection business logic
consists of
customized python apps integrated with
df lite quantized ai models that are
built and managed through google cloud
google cloud serves as the core cloud
platform
providing the edge and cloud-based ai
models
through automl the ai platforms for
especially like custom models
and industry-ready ai products such as
manufacturing visual inspection
as our solution includes edge iot
the cloud iot core supports edge
orchestration and device management
integration with fqtt and https
like interfaces the segmented or process
visual inspection data
generated through cloud or hai inference
the streaming or batch type are
transformed
with the google cloud data and ml
services supporting various business
applications such as
intelligent quality monitoring dashboard
or
custom real-time workflows running
either on the cloud or on-premise with
containerized
and those like solution we have been
successful
in productizing an innovative concept of
ai based visual inspection
to a client ready production solution is
mainly because of the technology value
google is bringing in
through a managed and scalable cloud ai
and data services
we have been able to achieve faster time
to value with minimum
efforts due to technology such as smart
data labeling tools on google cloud
that reduces your labeling efforts and
help in building efficient ai training
datasets
automl like products minimizes your ai
development efforts
and provide mature ai models for object
detection
object tracking and image classification
to support complex inspection
environments
you can build once and deploy your ai
model
either on the cloud or on the edge
offline supporting multiple ai
prediction channels supported by google
cloud
other managed google cloud ml and data
services
provide scalability and acceleration in
fulfilling real-time applications and ml
optimized reporting of ai inspected data
now each client story is different
however we have sketched
out a common approach that is a best
practice that allows us to deliver
fast and efficiently first we identify
the business
needs this involves understanding the
business case for each asset
and determining which assets are worth
pursuing
additionally we choose our approach when
we are looking for small items that are
hard to distinguish from backgrounds
we opt for segmentation however most of
our clients have found great success
in sticking to object detection services
from google cloud
to begin with defining the right data
set as
every data scientist know data is the
key
here we here we build our data sets
such that we have at least 100 labels
per classification of
object to begin with autonomy
accenture's advanced ai capabilities
bring expertise in building super
efficient data sets
with custom labeling techniques and data
augmentation
depending on the complexity of the
images or videos
and exclusively to improve the
performance of the models on whatever
we leverage automl object detection to
detect and classify
assets if we find the accuracy of the
model is lacking for particular assets
or if the data set needs to be
augmented with features or threshold
needs to be adjusted per asset
we turn to custom model development in
custom model development we use ai
platform notebooks to augment custom
models with pre-trained networks
to achieve best better accuracy all
available as part of google cloud ai
platform
we support complex model deployment and
predictions
this can then be published into
dashboards
with cloud predictions or deployed onto
edge
triggered by either manual events or
automated services
now on top of our technical platform
as mentioned before we are offering some
of our exclusive industry solutions
with tailored ai and application
services for enterprises
in energy for utilities we perform a
quality check of the utility poles
for upstream energy production industry
we provide safety services such as
real-time inspection of
leakage detection in a plant and worker
safety
gear compliance monitoring and hazard is
working in beyond
to address kovite 19 related challenges
at enterprises that are returning to
work we have a visual tracking solution
that monitors
safety distancing between workers and
face mask monitoring like services
in production environments involving
industrial workers we offer worker
productivity tracking services
in the retail industry such as at the
stores we offer
in-store customer behavior and shelf
stock monitoring for effective
stock recreation for life sciences in
the research sector
air visual inspection plays a key
productive role in performing quality
checks for the research samples
a new upcoming visual inspection
solution in partnership with
google involves bringing an end-to-end
quality inspection transformation for
semiconductors
starting from fabrication to the
component assembly
exclusively for the manufacturing
industry we are jointly working with
google
in bringing aibi transformation and
performing a quality checkup
for the product defects missing
compliance and missing product
components
now let me introduce some of our success
stories we have achieved with google
cloud
for utilities we developed an utility
ball inspection solution
to automatically and accurately identify
damaged utility
as well as healthy inventory equipments
on the poles
using exclusively google's automobile ai
product
the vision ai process data is further
processed and analyzed for
predictive maintenance and actionability
such the business value
that we delivered here was to provide
actionable insights for
wildfire mitigation scenarios and
improved asset tracking
for another utility provider we
developed a field worker mobile edge
visual inspection app
to perform quality check of the utility
poles during post installation and
maintenance
the aji visually processed utility pole
data
brought tremendous value in improving
the inspection process
at the back office reducing false
positive and false negative scenarios
for the inspectors at an
automotive manufacturing production
facility that involved monitoring
workers
at multiple stations in a production
line the challenge was
the assembly line supervisor had no
visibility to line imbalances or worker
bottlenecks
these bottlenecks and out of balance
conditions persisted for prolonged
periods
impacting productivity and quality to
address these challenges we built an
automl based edge object tracking
solution
deployed on google core iot gateway to
track and assess
the final assembly worker movements
within and outside
the assembly stations maintaining the
privacy of worker images
on the edge and transferring only the
segmented data to the cloud
thereby alerting supervisors when
bottlenecks
or out of balance conditions were
detected
and for our life sciences clients we
developed an autonomous
cobot visual inspection solution to
analyze bacteria samples
and access different quality types
before carrying out advanced research
here a programmed robotic arm picks up
petri dishes with samples
that have to undergo quality check and
places them under a camera
integrated with an edge gateway running
ai visual inspection models
analyzing these samples in real time and
then instructing these robotic arms to
place the different quality categories
of bacterias into a designated pig
the value we were able to provide here
is to effectively utilize
lab technicians time for higher
value tasks and let ai do the mundane
type of quality inspection checks
thereby reducing inspection time by 80
percent through automation
as well reducing the false positive
rates by 10 percent
for retail we built an ai and iot driven
visual inspection solution
on google cloud ai platform and google
corel
with the camera tracking inventory
levels of these promotional shelves
items in real time simultaneously
we also carried out performing planogram
compliance checks
and this inspected data alerted workers
to take actions
before they turn into like real business
problems with this
we were able to bring inventory
automation over coming out of inventory
scenarios
efficient labor utilization and improved
customer experience
and another value valuable experience we
conducted at retail is measuring
customer behavior in store
and this is to optimize in-store
customer experience with
better services and operations and all
this is done with the privacy first
mindset
processing customer visual data on the
edge
with this and my presentation and over
to you it
thanks sudhi next let's take a look at
the video from
siemens
[Music]
factories need artificial intelligence
to harness the power of
detailed data and consistently provide
granular metrics to increase quality
visual inspection ai automates quality
control process
and helps achieve cost savings improving
work efficiency
based on the learning and experience
gained with internal use cases
siemens is building ai products that we
offer to our customers
so we put together a technology stack
that runs ai models
in real time right on production lines
so that we can
intelligently inspect every single unit
produced
at siemens digital industries motion
control factory in erlangen we're
implementing ai for different use cases
in electronics manufacturing
we want to automate inspection processes
like circuit board assembly
soldering and packaging let's take a
closer look at one of our examples
every day at packaging stations we
prepare thousands of produced units and
accessories for shipping to our
customers
whether the operation is manual or
automated it can happen that smaller
accessories are mixed up or missing
with ai we can monitor the packaging
process in real time
and immediately notify the worker if a
package was incomplete
ai models can detect small objects in a
video stream
whatever their position on a conveyor
belt is
that was not possible with algorithms
before that required exact location of
all objects
and couldn't tolerate occlusion or
changes in lighting
with ai solutions we can minimize the
number of incomplete packages
and corresponding costs this increases
throughput
and eliminates rework
we use multiple core eye technologies
and on which those provided by google
for example cloud-based service ltml
is very convenient and for some
operations like
data annotation or model training even
colleagues from production engineering
or i.t
not specifically trained for data
science can perform them
we see the potential of ai and we are
implementing it
in our factories first to deliver well
thought
innovative and tested products to the
market
we believe artificial intelligence is
the future of automation
and essentially the future of
manufacturing
[Music]
thanks siemens team for sharing the
great story
at google cloud we appreciate the
collaboration with
all partners and customers for building
out the visual inspection solution to
transform
the manufacturing industry
thank you behalf of accenture i thank
google cloud team
for the joint collaboration and bringing
innovation to our clients
over to you inc if you would like to
learn more about this new solution
please reach out to your sales rep at
google cloud
and they will share more information
more details
about using the product with you thank
you
you